historiker video allerdings auch so was
man dort eben ja ich war mal das war
letztes jahr
hey was geht ab und letzte kam beim ein
video ja leute ich bin nach zehn jahren
mal wieder mit herz hier wir haben uns
schon länger nicht mehr gesehen und
haben gedacht wir machen ein video
weil wir beide gerade mal wieder
zusammen sind und dem rad schon wieder
bei harwich auf dem kanal gemacht und
zwar erkennt er es besser mit herab
freundin zusammen das solltet ihr euch
auch auf keinen fall entgehen lassen
also gleich vorbei schauen heute da sind
solche ratten handy haben mich einfach
übels gelingt und ich idiot noch drauf
reingefallen gelenkt meine freundin
gelingt ja aber am ende habt ihr beide
mich gelingt mein geheimnis ja nicht
gelingt werden nur schnitzer klug
geworden ist abgemacht hat das stimmt
oder haben wir mehr sagte einfach ja
okay und ich habe mir für heute was
überlegt was ich echt interessant finde
weil wir beide sind ja schon recht lange
auf youtube dabei und wir gucken auch
persönlich oft youtube verfolgen das
ganze natürlich und das haben wir so
gedacht ja lasst doch mal so ein hot or
not machen aber das finde ich so ein
bisschen oberflächlich wenn man einfach
so youtube dies ja ohnedies nicht gerade
deswegen deswegen habe deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht das ding ist ich bin so
einfach ich habe es so in meinem kopf
tun als wenn ich irgendwie nicht
zufrieden bin mit der betonung dann sage
ich das einfach weiter so und wenn
irgendwelche anderen leute im raum sind
und das halt so gar nicht gewohnt sind
dann lachen die mal was weil das ja
eigentlich halten
aber wir gucken wir beide auch
persönlich ab und zu mal weibliche
youtube drinnen und therapie freundin
carina hast du einen spitznamen hat sich
jetzt weibliche youtube rausgesucht und
wir müssen die hand des contents
bewerten und auch vielleicht ein
bisschen vom aussehen her wenn man so
gerne schaut weißt du und dann guckt man
mal messen lieblings youtube rinder am
ende bei rauskommen bei uns weil wir
sind ja eigentlich so ich bin gespannt
ob die selben meinung haben genauso
vertreten oder schweigen
unsere meinung sich komplett aber er ist
richtig ehrlich sein wir sind noch nicht
so weit
carina ist fertig gespannt und ja ich
bin ich bereit mich mal was im flugmodus
drin
eine ladies heute blogge ich euch mal
mit
also ich finde die richtig hübsch so
also sieht sympathisch aus aber was die
jetzt für videos macht weiß ich nicht
deswegen kann ich das nicht sagen ich
nur sagen ich kenne es schon etwas
länger habe sie ihre tricks an gemacht
sollte ich nur sagen ich kenne es schon
etwas länger und muss sagen sie ist
wirklich so mega sympathisch wir waren
auch auf dieser university da war die
auch der wohl zusammen getanzt haben
alles selber wurde richtig richtig
sympathische person und ihre videos oder
wird als junge kann man sich sogar ihre
videos voll gerne geben weil sie so ein
geiler humor später machen leute ich
verlinke natürlich auch alle kennen die
hier angesprochen werden in der
beschreibung also ich finde jetzt auf
jeden fall so alleine vom charakter
können sie die retten hat er ohne witz
charakter ist aus sicht aussehen
da kommt die nächste und waren wieder
katja klärte witzig ich wette da draußen
ich nicht dass ich dir und lassen dann
muss sondern von mir historiker video
ach so was ja ich war mal das war
letztes jahr
und zwar saß sie neben mir und dann kam
plötzlich so 13-jähriger oder so oder 12
13 waren hier und haben gefragt ob sie
die brüste anfassen dürfen von katja und
hat gesagt jeder macht mal und dann wird
halt weggeschickt weil die eltern
beschwert haben
wieso ich das gehört eigentlich finde
sie es auf jeden fall nett sympathisch
ich finde sie um ehrlich zu sein nicht
sonderlich attraktiv aber
das ding ist ich finde das cool dass sie
das so durchzieht und ich finde es auch
völlig okay dass es solche content gibt
auf youtube weil ich meine warum soll so
etwas nicht geben wir sind leben nicht
mehr im 19 jahrhundert oder so aber ich
gucke mir das jetzt nicht anderen feiert
das ist wirklich gut ist haben da muss
ich sagen dass song ist wirklich den
kammern sich geben
du bist ja vom aussehen sollte sie es
nicht so ganz mein fall nein ich finde
das ist dass er hat zuviel unecht ihre
lippen nase mittlerweile glaube ich auch
brüste da ich ob ich mir auch nicht mehr
ganz so schlecht ist sie sind vielleicht
auch wirklich nett ja ich wünsche euch
haben außer bioverfahrenstechnik person
mit der man sich nett unterhalten kann
hier noch über katharina nächsten ich
kann null mit ihrem ich weiß wie es
wollte ich kenne sie nicht ihre videos
schaue ich auch nicht also ich muss
sagen sie ist auf jeden fall finde ich
dass es so viele menschen einfach diese
ganzen videos schauen diese macht also
ich kann ich konnte mir das auch nicht
so gerne an und ich würde mal gerne so
das ein oder andere video wo ich denke
vielleicht interessieren mich ruhig
anbau sind ist doch süß so ja sie ist
natürlich genau das finde ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ich finde immer fragwürdig
wenn man halt dann schon etwas älter ist
um 25 oder 26 ob dieses 26 oder so ob
man da noch in so badewanne mit schleier
einspringen muss finde ich fragwürdig
also das würde ich nicht machen da
weiter das war nicht ganz genau mit mit
26 so jetzt vielleicht noch ich bin noch
ein bisschen kindisch manchmal drauf
aber ich weiß
diese frau elisa von freunden aussehen
dass und vor allem wie sie rede das war
erst im juni getrennt
die macht auf youtube und bis jetzt nach
deutschland gezogen
also ich finde ich auch auf jeden fall
natürlich hinüber ist auch richtig süß
wegen der akzent diese bosnische und
dann amerikanischen sendern wie die
versuche durchzugehen
richtig sind aber ich weiß jetzt gar
nicht mehr ich glaube ich habe noch nie
ich habe hier auch auf jeden fall
sympathisch gucke ich mir wirklich
überhaupt nicht an die videos auch wenn
was das einsieht dass nicht wirklich
aber persönlich die frau ist bombe die
frau ist bombast die schon persönlich
getroffen
ich habe schon mal gesehen ja die ist so
die person wenn es ist eigentlich ein
mann aber ich werde gleich verstehen
warum ich ihn mit reingenommen haben und
zwar als dass marvin möglichen hast
jetzt verstanden warum sie denn genommen
hat ja ich weiß dass warum weil der halb
make up gemacht
das ist der geht es auch zeichen
ich hab echt kalt jahren gedacht mich
sagen weil ich habe immer wieder an
video gesehen von dem er ich hab aber
zwei drei videos gesehen hat ich weiß
glaube das ist ich hab gedacht ich hab
dann auch in echt schon mal gesehen aber
ich glaube ich habe echt mal mit von ihm
video gesehen ich habe nur meinen video
gesehen wo er auch drin war aber das war
nicht von ihm sondern von diesem aus
sieglos ich kenne ihn nicht persönlich
habe noch nicht bin auch schon mal so
gesehen aber ich finde es immer sehr
mutig sich als man so etwas zutrauen
wollen es gibt echt viele jungs die sich
schminken somit mit 14 sendern das auf
youtube film also das hätte ich nicht
immer vor allem endlich konnte rasiert
als männliche die zähne diesel beauty
linke als man dachte möchte ich sehen
sie so reden aber es hat make up einfach
wahrscheinlich kommt die nächste
ich hätte ja auch richtig geld das ist
sehr sarah nowak harrison die macht um
19 uhr
die macht youtube richtig aktiv ja doch
ein freund ich und jetzt ist auch ein
kind bekommen das sollte man abends
also ich keine ahnung was sie für
youtube-videos macht das einzige was ich
halt echt
das einzige was ich nicht machen würde
ist mein kind so oft ins programm zu
zeigen
das ist natürlich das kann man
unterschiedlich sehen aber warum jemand
doch gar nicht weiß ob das kind so damit
glücklich ist weißt du das kind da noch
gar kein falsch verstand entwickelt das
sehe ich auch so wenn irgendwer seinen
kleinen bruder ryan und in irgendwelche
videos immer weiße finde ich auch nicht
cool so weist der kann das ja gar nicht
sagen aber das möchte da nicht wieso
einmal soweit okay aber wenn er immer
drinnen oder wenn du ein baby wird ein
baby zeigt und dass eine million
menschen sehen das würde ich nicht
machen aber control an wie du das machst
ok ich persönlich glaube herrscht diese
weise das war früher in wirklichkeit ist
die ware nach santa cruz die kann tanzen
aber was die durch youtube-videos macht
visionär youtube hat ja auch mal vor
videos gemacht wo die allzu kannst also
da kann ich nichts zu sagen ich kenne
sie wirklich schon früher freunde wie
waren früher relativ auf zucker feiern
mit ihren ihrer besten freundin damals
meter sind partys nein wirklich das
mädchen ist wirklich sehr nett auch
persönlich richtig nett wie ich kenne
sie wirklich dass es schon ports
firewire dann kann man wie sich so immer
mehr wohnhäuser sobald die karte gleich
aus ich bin tot mal vielleicht finde ich
ja ein video weiß ich schon geheilt
werden kann und was würdest du jetzt
sagen wer ist so deine lieblings youtube
drin wenn du am liebsten hätte ich mich
am meisten auf youtube sagen okay und
auch seine mitspieler martin war jetzt
wirklich dass man kennt sie sie es mega
net also ich gucke salome jetzt nicht
jedes video aber irgendwie ab und zu hab
ich da mal rein sonst gucke ich halt
echt kein und kein mädchen so ich auch
nicht ja heute das was mit dem video
statt auf jeden fall bei herbei und
guckt wer heraus besser kennt wir sind
uns wahrscheinlich morgen wieder ich
wünsche euch noch einen schönen angenehm
tag und drei leute ich bin's katja